hello so today is a very special day
it's the 4th of knocked-over no November
so today is a very special day it's the
fourth of November 2010 it's a bad day
in that two years ago today proposition
8 was passed in the state of California
resulting in the elimination of gay
couples being able to marry I'm not
getting myself I am a supporter of gay
rights as you can tell from this lovely
t-shirt that I am currently sporting but
today is also a very special day for me
because it's my 3-year seven month and
one day anniversary on YouTube I think
you'll agree that the three year seven
month of one-day anniversary is a
milestone in any youtubers career and
your let me on to thinking about one of
the big questions what why am I here
what am I doing here on YouTube why why
well if you're interested in my origin
story I have done a bit of remembering
as to why I am here it turns out that
the reason I'm here can be bored down to
two very specific moments in time the
first one which is seemingly unimportant
but ultimately very much so is the first
time that I ever played ocarina of time
on the Nintendo 64 Ocarina of Time is my
favorite video game if it wasn't for
that game then I wouldn't wanted to make
sure film parodying that video game and
if it wasn't for that parody then I
wouldn't have made a youtube account to
which to upload that film yes that's the
reason I wanted to set up a YouTube
account so I could upload a short film
which was a parody of a video game that
I liked and no that short film never got
finished nor do I know where the files
are so unfortunately it's one of those
things that is just kind of lost to the
world so the short film is not what's
important if it wasn't for that game I
wouldn't have set up a youtube account
which brings me on to the second thing
which is paramount to me being here
today here on the internet there is a
video and it's called the like a chain
resurrected and it is the first video
that I ever saw which introduced me to
the YouTube community it was one of
those videos that was featured on the
front page of YouTube and it was
basically just a guy talking about all
of his favorite youtubers after watching
that video I decided to go and check out
some of the youtubers that were
mentioned and it was after watching
those youtubers people like Kaelyn Hale
bluntly through thousand that I
discovered video blogging
I mean sure if I hadn't seen that video
that I probably would have gone on to
find some other YouTube video which
introduced me to video blogging but on
this timeline of my life that video is
the important one to me
and so on this 3 year 7 month and one
day anniversary I've decided that I am
going to continue the like a change and
the important thing about this is that
if you want to make a video response
continuing on the like a change talking
about people that you like to watch on
YouTube please do but now finally if
still with us it's time for me to talk
about my favorites number one with his
crazy clothing antics and his plethora
even jokes he's the favorite of many
here on the YouTube website seriously
his videos are brilliant and I'm
actually hoping to go and hang out of
him and she can't do a mix of videos
with him next month so number two elmify
she's so fly she's definitely one of
those people who you know might not have
the best equipment or the ability to
make explosions happen in her bedroom
but regardless ever sets up she
consistently just transcends that by
being extremely hilarious and very very
witty and very smart as well also she
likes to make jokes about the fact that
she has a bit of a crush on me I don't
know whether or not she actually does
but you know as me that's something that
I enjoy obviously Brett Domino he's got
the flow Brett Domino he's got the flow
red Domino he's got the flow he's
definitely one of the most underrated
and also just brilliantly talented
YouTube musicians and I wish he had a
bigger following all of his videos are
really good in terms of like musical
talent and technical quality and he's
really funny as well and I've met him
and he's really nice you know he's one
of those good things and last but not
least because she'd kill me if I didn't
mention her my mum makes YouTube videos
did you know my mum makes YouTube videos
she's called Lily's are like smokes my
mum my mum and I'm not just saying watch
her because she's my mum I'm saying she
is my mum but also her videos are quite
good so she should watch yeah so there
you go mum I've told him about you now
you're happy I do watch a lot of people
on YouTube and I have any mentioned a
few of them but if you want to continue
on the like of change feel free to talk
about as many or as little people as you
want so obviously one is the minimum
don't talk about no people that would
not be fun
and I think that's the end so the end
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool